[Music]
so my name is Bob City I'm a VP of cloud
engineering for Atos and I'm currently
based in London for those of you close
enough to the front of the stage to be
able to count the Rings under my eyes I
think you can correlate that to the
number of hours difference between
London and San Francisco so in today's
session we are going to look at the role
of hybrid clouds in acceleration
transformation - cloud is a really big
topic it is quite complex there's a lot
of technologies involved so we can
really only scratch the surface but
before we start that I like to just make
a quick introduction about what data
says who we are and what we do so a
toast or a global digital services
leader operating in 73 different
countries we've got in excess of 120
thousand people with an annual revenue
of circa 12 billion years we provide a
quite a wide variety of IT services
spanning from digital transformation
managed services application development
application transformation security Big
Data you name it we do it well
established organization April last year
we announced a global enhanced alliance
partnership with Google focusing on
hybrid cloud machine learning AI digital
workplace and security and I'm very
proud that this year we've been
recognized as the Google cloud global
breakthrough partner so artists on
Google are driving six distinct
innovation tracks focusing on increasing
application agility and able enabling s
AP on cloud I oh t enhanced real-time
collaboration artificial intelligence
and secure hybrid clouds
so the agenda for today in today's
session we're going to start by putting
a little bit of business context around
what it is that enterprises are striving
to do and we're going to try to drill
down from that position into what sort
of transformations need to take place
we're also going to look at some of the
typical challenges that enterprises
experience and how working with a
trusted partner can alleviate some of
those burdens and we'll move into the
role of holistic hybrid clouds in
helping to accelerate and hopefully I'm
going to be able to get the time to also
spend a few minutes to tell you about a
product launch that we did this Tuesday
at Google next for our newest hybrid
cloud offering and we'll close this
session with a bit of Q&A and if there
isn't sufficient I'm more than happy to
take questions after the session and
obviously we'll be at the stall in
chardee so regardless of the sector and
enterprise organization is within
operating within there are quite a lot
of common themes that we all strive to
achieve today especially in the context
of a global digital market we see these
things across pretty much all of our
customers and actually we recognize
those exact same things internally
within our own organization and they're
relatively simplistic we all strive for
agility the ability to be the disrupter
rather than the disrupted we strive to
have data-driven businesses where the
decision making is based on analytics
and real-time data we want to increase
our revenue base through the
introduction of differentiated offerings
and we want to do that in a way where we
are cost controlling and making sure the
solutions are pulling together our cost
optimal and competitive so to achieve
these aims there is quite a lot of
change that's required business
processes need to change in order to
provide agility security processes need
to change in order to provide agility
and equally your application development
method all
themselves need to be changing to give
you that agility looking at a
data-driven decision-making sort of
scenario again your application space
needs to be able to support that there
needs to be a consolidation of your data
in order to be able to effectively apply
machine learning and analytics to your
data and equally from a revenue and cost
perspective well in order to actually
find what's a differentiator in the
market you need real data and you need
the real analytics again is that their
data to understand what the demand in
the market is automation plays
absolutely huge part in ensuring that we
got a cost-effective solution and we are
able to control the costs and be
competitive and equally cloud native
solutions enable you to really it's the
utility model is utilizing resources at
the point you need them being able to
scale up and down in line with the
agility of your business so I want to
drill down another level further than
from this and look at really what are
the transformational spaces that we need
to look into so from a business process
perspective this is the absolute bare
minimum we need to enable the business
to be able to make decisions based on
data and analytics IT operations
majority of our other organizations we
work with are still I tool based they
use IT Service Management to link in
order to manage the environments and
processes and to achieve the actual
agility that we require me to start
moving more and more and more towards
deaf setups you're gonna hear me repeat
the word deaf sack ups over and over in
this and hopefully it's nothing new to
anyone here but it's actually really
complex and really hard space to get
into especially when your starting point
is traditional IT operations security
again embedding security in the
application development space as opposed
to it being a wrapper after the fact and
the biggest challenge at the moment is
we're in the era of multi cloud hybrid
cloud on-premise solutions
and coming up with processes and
technologies and tools that actually are
able to effectively span all three of
those spaces to give you a consolidated
view of your security is a tough task
similar with your processes around
security not unlike the rest of IT
services I think automation is
absolutely key within the security space
so we need to look at the ways of
automating security processes security
testing security governance within or
essentially it's things like our CIC the
pipeline's policy driven architectures
where why we can articulate policies the
security policies and other business
policies in a way where the technology
can enforce them and anyone who is
working in in sort of regulated
industries or with governmental bodies
will be aware of the amount of work that
needs to be done with the legislative
bodies with the government bodies in
essentially trying to bring them up to
speed with the cloud negative
technologies they have to go on the same
transformation and understanding and
learning that we all do and it's we have
to bring them along with us so this is a
this is not a short-term fix and it's
going to take some time and later on
we'll look at some ways that we can try
to help accelerate at least parts of
this process so that is not the whole
thing is not a serial application
development back to dev psych ops
putting the appropriate practices in
place so we are able to effectively get
agility out of our or application
development space putting the right
quality assurance and testing
capabilities including the security we
touched upon within our CI CD pipelines
adoption of all these new technologies
so kubernetes
cloud functions acts as a service by X
as a service I'm talking about things
like PA's SAS database as a service a
IML as a service Big Data as a service
so all of those total technologies need
to be adopted why do they need to be
adopted because they form the building
blocks of your applications Europe your
applications and developers do not have
to recreate those things from scratch
they're ready to be consumed and it's
critical that we start moving our
applications towards using those
ready-made services and building blocks
that are managed by managed service
providers so your business can
concentrate on developing applications
for a line of business as opposed to
caring about the under-the-hood IT and
we gotta be realistic at this point in
time our vast majority of the
applications that are in the enterprise
space are still not cloud native at a
rough guess I would say 95% of the
applications are non cloud native and
that's probably somewhat generous so we
still gotta be aware that we've got a
significant portion of work to do in
order to transform replace refactor
those applications to get them to cloud
native space data consolidation so
separation of the code from data is
absolutely key and especially when we
start looking at technology such as
kubernetes where essentially the code
base is running in a pod that pod can be
killed it can be recreated as many times
as you like it can be scaled up it can
be scaled down their data mustn't be
affected for not so separating code from
data is absolutely crucial at this stage
and it's a real difficult task to be
with legacy applications we also have to
look at centralization and normalization
of that data in order to then
effectively apply analytics if anyone's
worked with sort of the AI ml type of
technologies machine learning it's it's
somewhat of a area where there's a lot
of experimentation required you're not
always sure about the viability of a
particular idea being model able in an
effective way through machine learning
so experimentation is required and we
need to build capabilities where we can
do proof of concepts but they rapidly
take a proofs of proof of concept that
we've shown to be working into a
production level application
and this probably worthwhile mentioning
from an AI ml perspective and analytics
as a whole it's a bi-directional
relationship in terms of the way whether
it drives the business or the business
drives it so your practice is from a IML
perspective have got to be able to
respond to business demand and be able
to model things and predict things as
the business requires but equally we got
to be open to the challenges that
information and analytics lead sources
can lead to us changing our business
models Automation again it's an
absolutely theme throughout this
presentation in being able to automate
as much of the processes because your
agility is highly dependent on it and we
are getting to a space at the moment
where more and more things are getting
easier to automate and we gotta ensure
things like Quality Assurance testing
and the security side are really
effectively addressed through the
automation piece and CIC D is one answer
CIC D is a methodology CIC D enables you
to encode your business rules and
practices your security capability is
testing from from our own internal
perspective for example when we're
developing our cloud platforms our CI CD
pipelines actually include whole set of
security testing around scanning the
code for quality for inadvertent
insertion of vulnerabilities for
upstream reliance on upstream libraries
that may have vulnerabilities included
within them and the QA sort of thing is
equally so we want to get to a point
where an application developer checking
code in automatically triggers our whole
set of pipelines that will automatically
give you to a point where you have
confidence that code is sufficiently
tested to directly deploy into
production that's where you get your
agility from and that's got a cover
security and the technology and
everything else to do with it it's gotta
be policy driven again going back to the
point of being able to encode
business rules policies legislative
rules policies all of those things in a
way where they can programmatically be
tested as part of your ability to deploy
and also to build your solutions and
we've gotta adopt all the cloud native
technology so those are who are familiar
with kubernetes space probably
understand the analogy of cattle versus
pets when when we look at the current
existing set of applications we're
dealing with enterprise applications are
typically very stateful we really care
about the state of our virtual machines
and our servers if they die they take
things down with them that affects our
business in cloud native world we are in
a complete different scenario
we don't patch a server we create a new
port we create a new pod we start
directing some of the traffic towards
that pod if it's successful and it's not
failing we start diverting all of the
traffic to the new pod and we get the
rid of the old one so mentality wise is
a mindset shift your application
development and QA processes it's a
shift and actually gaining agility but
he said has a reliance on your
applications being architected in a way
where they able to support that kind of
mechanism and your operational practices
has got to be aligned to being able to
do the kind of testing to be able to
understand the effect of introducing a
new version of a service and directing
the portion of unity and canary testing
for example so it's a lot of work to be
there to be done there and I mentioned
this before around the X as a service
whatever it is as a service adoption of
those in order to accelerate the actual
application development process so the
cloud challenge we are transforming far
more than the IT we're barely skirting
around the edges of of the non-id
elements in this particular presentation
but there are cultural shifts that need
to happen there are business processes
that need to happen this
security processes there's legislative
stuff that we've got to deal with when
we look at our typical customer
scenarios of what they go through when
they start looking at transformation and
moving to public cloud quite often the
starting point is looking at the
regulatory and compliance needs that
typically forms some sort of a concept
or architecture and what they need to do
for security and their networking and
usually it's fairly traditional base rod
and cloud native approaches that are
adopted because at that stage all of us
are in the same boat we haven't quite
learned what we need to be doing then we
start looking at selective applications
being transformed or adopting ready-made
cloud native applications in order to to
satisfy our needs so we then end up in a
position we've got selective
applications our own public cloud the
rest of our environment is still in a
non cloud native mode and not on Prem it
is usually at this stage that most
businesses that we have been working
with have a realization that the pace of
public cloud adoption is far far slower
than they would like and in order to
accelerate that most organization go
down the path of looking at lift and
shift there's a few problems so we've
got our existing application space the
legacy applications or traditional
application space which is now cloud
native traditional operations around it
traditional security around it you're
talking about change control boards cabs
people approving changes being applied
into production and now we've got a set
of applications which are completely
different in the way they're being
managed I'm their cloud native living in
public cloud so one or two things can
happen
you either enforce your existing IT
processes on top of your cloud native
stuff that been deployed on public cloud
in which case you are reducing the
agility of that entire solution or you
end up in a mixed mode of operations
where the cloud native stuff is dealt
with in a different way to to your
on-prem or traditional applications and
if it's not planned upfront really well
you end up with an inconsistent
application of controls so
governance IT governance technical
governance security governance you can
end up in a position where you have a
complete mismatch and inability to
consciously say that you've applied your
governance practices equally across the
board so when we start looking at a
holistic hybrid cloud and I'm
intentionally keep putting the word
holistic here because it's much more
than just the cloud platforms themselves
we start looking at a holistic hybrid
cloud ecosystem what does it do the
extents and brings the cloud to your
premises simplistic allows you to do a
coexistent model and a bimodal mode of
operations so we have to delve into that
much more but there are certain
characteristics that these clouds need
to have in order to enable that but they
also enable us at least in the short
term to predict it protect our existing
investments and you know we we have a
hell of a lot of customers who are going
through this journey to public cloud and
the reality of situation is and this is
not uncommon we we talk to them and
they've got a 10-year lease on a
datacenter that cannot be changed
overnight they've got that existing
investment and finally where we are
protecting the existing investment is
critical and I think hybrid clouds is
one way to address that in the short
term so are the characteristics of a
hybrid cloud in order to enable those
things these are opinionated need to be
open standards and native API based by
that I mean for example open source
standard API is there are not
proprietary and that is to enable
essentially integration with
orchestration tools with CMP tools there
are available out there without getting
locked in any true hybrid hybrid
capability in order to such that if you
start developing your applications on
the private cloud element of a hybrid
you don't have to spend the same R&D or
application development time to then
transform them to run on public you
development work once you do it once in
a true hybrid cloud environment you
should be able to have full portability
in order to move them to public lab when
the rest of the processes and things
that you need to change within the
organisation are ready for it CIC the
end policy-driven
architecture we've talked about already
absolutely crucial that your hybrid
cloud solutions are able to support
these methodologies and again it goes
back to the to the point of being able
to present out standardized non
proprietary open api's that means that
whatever work you do in developing your
CIC any pipelines again is reusable
regardless of what cloud you're running
on and this is another key point so we
still have got our existing traditional
IT service processes they're not gonna
go over it over away overnight and we
need to maintain those services and
processes in order to ensure governance
is still there so we still need a way of
bridging the old and a new so a true
hybrid cloud solution needs to give you
the capability whereby you're
integrating your actual processes you're
ITSM toolsets
with that platform but in a way where
it's not affecting agility and the
ability to you see icd capabilities it's
a hard thing to do but I think that is
an absolutely crucial requirement for a
true hybrid cloud solution
many of you know adoption of public
cloud again it's a it's a topic that is
driven sometimes by motion it to be
truly successful in adopting cloud your
developers need to love working in that
environment they need to see advantage
they need to see a different way of
working they would have to like it if
they don't like it they will go and do
something else
that's the reality we've seen adoption
of public cloud come about in pockets of
line of business applications within our
clients purely because the developers
like the ecosystem that they have on
public cloud so to make a hybrid cloud
successful we need to ensure we are
providing the developers with the same
set of care
abilities the same set of tools that
they actually want to use and helps them
to develop their applications on Prem so
why is it different this time there's
been so many iterations of technologies
changing new things coming along
we had virtualization 10 years back
coming along and with the promises that
would completely transform the way we do
businesses I do think we're at the
unique point at the moment we've got a
real convergence of the convergence of
the infrastructure application and
security technologies methodologies all
of those things coming together so dev
check ups CICE capabilities automated QA
cloud native stateless applications AI
ml analytics all of these things have
come to converge at the same time to
enable us to do for more successes as
successful sort of transformation than
we were able to do before and a hybrid
cloud environment has got to enable you
to take advantage of all those
technologies and has to actually drive
the usage of those technologies so we've
only barely touched on these things but
there's a hell of a lot of new
technologies there's a hell of a lot of
new processes new ways of thinking about
things there's a lot of learning to be
done by by the entirety of our
organizations it's challenging it's
really crucial I think for everyone to
think about working with trusted
partners that can help them work through
some of these challenges bring the right
skills to the table and help
organizations adapt their existing
application development practices to be
to be a deficit corpse based teach you
about the technologies where it's
necessary and adopt all of these things
I think it's crucial to try to avoid all
of the typical pitfalls by getting help
from your trusted partners in our case
when we have a partnership between
someone that is helping you transform
your business and the cloud provider is
a three-way partnership which brings a
lot more value
so I'm going to quickly summarize the
stuff that we talked about and today
transformation is at every level it's
not just in a technology space it is in
the people space it is in the culture of
the organization it is the entirety of
your business processes your security
processes your application development
processes so it is at every single level
this is the price of getting agility if
you want your businesses to be agile and
be able to compete and come up with
those differentiated offerings this is
the sort of transformation that needs to
be taking place we need to get to a
place where we're able to encode
business processes or governance or
security all into automated ways of
being applied applying those so see ICD
through automated policy enforcement
then we have to ensure that whatever
solutions we put forward or capable of
supporting these things hybrid clouds
can significantly accelerate movement to
cloud public cloud cloud overall
adoption of cloud why because they allow
you to paralyze your activities so if
you looked at that typical scenario
scenario that was talking through
earlier where we were talking to the
legislators or governing bodies see what
we're allowed to do looking at changing
our security practices and look at
changing our network practices once
we're done that we start doing pockets
of applications if you have a hybrid
cloud environment to do your development
work on and it's got all of the same
capabilities or the vast majority of the
core capabilities and you need for your
developers to do cloud native
application development but on Prem
within the confines of your own security
space your existing network space etc
you're paralyzing that set of activities
so by nature you're going to shorten the
timescales required to do the overall
transformation and it's kind of leading
by example when it comes to bringing
their legislators or auditing bodies
alongside with you you have real-life
examples running on Prem that are
compliant to the existing security
requirements but also demonstrate what
can be done
we talked about the hybrid clouds
needing to provide the right ecosystem
that developers want to adopt and
they've got to be developer centric if
we don't hit that piece like I said your
developers will go elsewhere do it some
other way and we end up with that mixed
governance model and the inability to
apply the right level of governance
controls where all of us including me on
a learning journey continuously these
technologies some of these technologies
are bleeding edge they're developing it
every day something new happen something
new functionality comes out so it's
working with your trusted partners in
order to accelerate and D risk a
transformation so I'm really proud and
excited to present the Atlas open hybrid
cloud platform which was launched on
Tuesday morning at this event I'm going
to try to keep the marketing elements of
this to a bare minimum
but in short OHC is a managed hybrid
cloud platform and that at a base level
provides both iOS and kubernetes in the
same box which means you have dynamic
scaling between the two it provides sass
and past services that are mirroring
what is on GCP databases service big
data as a service a IML he has got
hybrid capabilities so I'm sure you've
seen the keynote speeches and anthos
anthos is embedded within this product
and you are able to use this product in
both a true private mode so if you're
not quite ready to open up your network
and have a true hybrid capability you
can start off with a big private and
dynamically change configuration to move
it into a hybrid mode
Otzi is cost optimized it is entirely
based on open source technologies and we
have been working with our partners
Google to ensure the set of technologies
that we built on this platform are api
compatible and again going back to the
point of being able to develop your
applications once and deploy many into
any cloud that's the work that we've
been doing for the past four months in
order to ensure other interoperability
from a DevOps perspective all the api's
are available for consumption the native
API is there are no proprietary API is
everything that it is on the platform is
open standards all the third-party tools
for orchestration CMPs etc all integrate
with it out of a box it is really
intended as a gateway to accelerate move
to public cloud and it is extremely
developer centric so like I said all of
the api's are fully exposed that and
they are the native API so we are the
first Google partner to implement anthos
on top of OpenStack there's a lot of
advantages on that front including their
costs so other things but we it does
allow us to offer a platform which is a
combination of the IRS and the cast side
of things but more crucially the
ecosystem that you see on the screen it
isn't just the hosting elements of a
cloud platform it is all the data
services the key data services that any
application developer developing micro
services would want to use and above and
beyond that your capabilities around AI
ml there's variants of this in terms of
the hardware models where we've got very
high end GPU acceleration so again you
can do even the cube flow and AI ml
aspects of it on this platform the
solution itself incorporates the concept
of policy engine policy engine and let
me be clear about this because there's a
there's a lot of different uses of the
word policy engine many people think of
it in terms of identity access
management that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about policies that
represent genuine business level
policies so
take an example an application has got a
requirement to be PCI DSS compliance so
that application can be tagged to be PCI
DSS compliant your pipelines and your
policy engine must prevent that
application being deployed on top of a
platform which is not PCI DSS compliant
and when it gets down to the level of
the actual technical components and the
way the services are delivered and the
characteristics our platform
that's where the policy enforcement
comes in and is able to discern whether
this platform is suitable to deploy such
an application on top of it could be
more simplistic than that geofencing so
we know many countries around the world
have got policies about certain data not
leaving their perimeters we're able to
for example apply geofencing policy that
says the application can be deployed in
this particular instance of the private
cloud or in that region of a public
cloud but not others
so we're talking about the high level
business level policies which then our
solution translate into a much lower
level granule technical implementation
of those policies so there's a couple
more elements I want to show one so we
talked earlier on about hybrid clouds
integrating with existing ìtell
processes ITSM tool sets so we have
created a level of abstraction in this
specifically for that purpose so we have
a sort of message bosses which are
actually based on Google pops up where
we are able to publish all the messages
from event alerting and CMDB
perspectives or you create a new
instance of instance of a virtual
machine or you create new kubernetes
cluster or you spin up a new
applications on kubernetes the events
will be published so they can be
consumed by existing tool sets you can
still apply your auditing and compliance
using your existing tool sets the
solution itself has not got a reliance
to manage services around the solution
or DevOps mode and don't have a reliance
on those ideas and tools but it does
allow that bimodal operation
and marrying up the existing oil
processes with the develop side of
things so talking about that message
boss and the pops up we have an
implementation of pops up within this
platform itself we work with Google to
to actually create a solution where
whereby we've got 100% an API compatible
version of pops up running free locally
and in hybrid mode it creates a
connection to GCP and gives you a single
message boss across GCP and your private
cloud it's a really powerful concept
because it does mean that events all of
those types of things again can be
correlated and collected in a multi
cloud or hybrid cloud scenario
centralized viewed analyzed all those
things become possible when you've got
ability to span with one set of
technologies message buses across one or
more clouds the manage databases managed
Big Data services again these are
accelerators and because there are API
compatible with with the Google services
it's the same concept of write the
application once and you're able to
deploy and consume it in multiple clouds
private or on-premise or non-public
we've got demos of our platform in the
stall and I would really welcome you to
come and join us so these are live demos
they're not pre-recorded we've got a
number of different ones we got our
overview where we just show you around
what the what the product looks like and
what they Piz offers and the user
interface within it we demonstrate a
hybrid application being deployed onto
the private cloud the same hybrid
application being deployed to public
cloud and then we split that application
into multiple parts or the front-end web
services for example run on GCP using a
history of service mesh communicating
back to database services running on
prem so your data stayed on Prem your
web service is scalable bursts out if
you like into public so it's quite
powerful
and we have got a demo of anthos so we
can actually go into google console we
see the private cloud as appearing as a
region within the GCP console you can go
into the marketplace you can select an
application for marketplace and deploy
it directly onto the private cloud it's
quite a powerful thing to be able to use
the marketplace all the work that goes
into creating these template of the
applications and being able to reuse
those regardless of the fact that you're
running on Prem
[Applause]
[Music]